before this video begins I have an
exciting announcement that that look
cooler in my head
I designed my own chair BAM look at that
Oh sexy sexy oh it's so soft in the butt
oh now I didn't know buy these chairs
first but as soon as I had it I was like
oh man this is too comfortable this is
the best thing ever
my ass has been thanking me every single
day is so goddamn comfortable and it's
so goddamn sexy so I worked together
with clutch it's all designed by me
you got the classic PewDiePie sexy legs
the chair is heavy-duty steel frame
aluminium base it's solid it's solid the
armchairs four different directions if
you got crazy arms
I got you fam they come with a head
trick it comes with the wrists got dim
this thing double thickness just like
this one oh my god and if you got a
little extra as my friend Ethan would
say Fupa
don't worry this chairs got you but I
haven't even shown you the best this is
the best thing it's a little scary at
first but once you get the hang of it
it's hella tech man so so the series of
this chair usually cost for $69.99 if
you get the regular one you get the
pretty PI one i hook you guys up BAM
$3.99 god damn it boy it works well for
console gaming PC gaming and it's a
limited edition with limited quantity so
don't wait and you won't be disappointed
I'm just so glad I can finally show the
damn thing cuz it's been a little hidden
in my videos for the longest time I've
just been having it down like this just
so like you can't see it finally ah I
can sit comfortably so if you want yours
I highly recommend it I've been sitting
on such a
bad chair for so long and it's been so
frustrating and I just been refusing to
get a proper one and now that I have one
I am so happy with it I love the design
I think it's so cool
it looks dope it really stands out from
most of these type of ones so yeah if
you want one link of this in the
description really appreciate it and
send me your pics if you get one with
the video begin Slender Man you've all
heard of him what one started as an
innocent Photoshop contest turning into
a pop-culture phenomenon Slender Man
undoubtedly had a huge impact on my
channel especially when I was younger I
would go on bro army dotnet or PT pi
calm I think it was before and I would
go to that suggestions page where a lot
of you guys could suggest me games to
play and but there was one thread
legendary thread made by give me $20 he
suggested that I would play the latest
Slenderman games there was one called
Slenderman which ident
I did actually play later but he also
recommended another one called the
second one is simply called slender the
download link is here the a is Paris and
the music will keep users in suspense
I immediately play this game I remember
I went online to see if anyone else
played it because back in the day
YouTube was all about who could play the
new popular game first it doesn't really
it doesn't really work like that anymore
I would say at least but I was like holy
[ __ ] this game looks amazing and no one
has played it I made sure to double
check like I'm gonna be the first this
is sick this is my big this is my
biggety biggety boo if you don't know
the history of Slenderman it basically
started as a Photoshop contest on
something off full forums it then sort
of became a meme on the internet a lot
of fan art was made from it
so I've heard of Slenderman before and I
knew it was like a big meme and that's
why I knew if the if there ever was a
Slenderman horror game that would be
really be popular and so I played it in
Italy in that little basement look at me
horror game it seems pretty basic I
think it was made for a competition or
I'm mixing it up with something else I
think it made I am pet and I only
collect all is the nut lick boy huh guys
nice though this reminds me of Haunted
investigation maybe this good old
haunted investigation right it's the
first time I ever I'm a girl oh my god
the reaction quickly was so terrifying
oh my god so creams you did well it
spawned a lot of other slender videos
and a lot of other slender games so many
slender games but everyone on YouTube
was playing slender like all the big
channels people started making gaming
channels you know slender is everywhere
it's such a such a huge deal for you to
buy it was this is like nowadays we have
drama and like vlogs keeping keeping the
trends but back in the day it was
slender I remember screaming so loud and
mice as parents was in the home I was
like are they okay I'm sorry I yelled
somehow but I thought you know we have
to play the game we gotta check it out
the original G copy how scary could it
be whoa parsec productions which also
made slender another slender version
later which was kind of disappointing I
guess collect all eight pages that's all
you know look at its stock unity
Forrest you know this is like as simple
as it gets man but the lack of
visibility the fact that the flashlight
goes down when you run I don't know it
makes it scary I think something about
the woods really scare me as well
especially growth growing out by the
woods in Sweden I really oh it almost
freaked me out and not knowing well is
out it's so easy to hide you know behind
the trees and shiz alright I know I'm
fine until like until I get a couple
paid this oh my god alright I'm a girl
I have tents oh yeah and there was this
building I was like what is in this
building I'm so scared it's just like a
skeleton of a building like what is this
oh my god you really do run out of
stamina fast I don't know if I ever beat
the game to be honest it was really hard
to get all eight like I remember trying
super hard but then again I wasn't such
a pro gamer back then I can't even find
one page - there it is nice dude I'm
getting goose bumps
I'm not joking this game gives me goose
bumps till it just did tension so well
the building of tension like oh [ __ ] I'm
doing something wrong I'm not supposed
to do this
oh my god it's still scare I'm still
like getting smoked out this is
ridiculous
Crowther Alf Felix okay it's just a
stupid Slenderman I'm not scared of
slander main I remember there's a spawn
here but god damn she's low where you
have yet to meet our friend our compadre
oh oh something's happening let's not go
that way I guess no man I get itchy when
I'm sweating man I don't like him this
game is making me nervous is he over
there he must be over there oh there he
is oh my god I am so scared of you you
are so spooky your sports Buki mister
man okay okay
all right we got it what up mister
Slendy he lookin sexy as always ironies
really just teleporting around too like
there's no character animation it really
shows how just in games like in movies
simplicity and horror works so much
better
well I forgot how [ __ ] this game once
ah it's so uneventful dude 2017 food if
I would have just quit by now did I
check this one there it is oh wow we'd
get the super-scary now that I have
today god damn I gotta get four more I
mean five more math is related to
science yeah oh look he's up our ass now
boy Oh what is this other dissipater
there let's go friend for mother okay
whoa
you're doing good man hell yeah I'm
gonna get although I'm gonna get all of
them slender oh the good old flem
goddamn I'm so itchy I'm like ah stop
making me sweat Slenderman I don't like
it I'm not in bed ready for you baby
show me those tentacles the sex jokes
have not stopped apparently great
oh well I guess we're not going that way
[Music]
okay I guess we're not going that way
either oh my god we're just walking the
circle dude Oh fine ah what the hell
dude on my scared shut up uh pathetic
man pathetic what do I even need the
pages for huh what am I gonna do with
them how is that gonna stop him how
about I just go to the home what the
heck I didn't even do anything
oh shoot oh shoot
game is this farting in my face now like
what the eye is right thing dude it's so
dark like a this is even on where am I
oh snap any movie
whoa what is this I found something
is that another note yes come on number
five and that's the way the news goes I
can't I can't see anything do I'm blind
leave my flashlight and run out oh yeah
well I guess I ran out of time because I
was too slow but a that five pages not
bad eh not bad eh what have we got the
extras I could play without a flashlight
I can play with a dildo is that it Wow
so that was slender the eight pages
it's funny how five years later it still
makes me sweat man
oh my god I feel like I sort of moved
away from the hard stuff mainly cuz I'm
kinda bored with it it's been I played
every game I played every single indie
horror game ever I don't know it just
doesn't have the same impact on me I
mean yeah I'd be a fool if it's still
dead
that doesn't mean I still enjoy it and
I'd really look back at slender as some
fond memories of the channel that being
said there are some horror games coming
out that I'm looking forward to play on
this channel evil within looks fun I
think we will do a playthrough that and
then maybe that will be something
interesting or not I don't know that's
the point of horror you never know if
it's going to be good thank you guys so
much for watching leave a like if you
enjoyed and Squad fan out